Này 2018, tên Vô Tên giả thông tin từ miệng Kremlin cho biết,
của đam Phán Phá Vén đầu tiên giới lý bằng Ngà Ukhhoi Nè và Mỹ,
dễn xa và cuối ngày theo dưới phương tại Thu Đô,
A Bú đã bị cuộc các tiểu vương của ở Đập Hứng nhất của ai.
Để được xem là bước đi mởi trong lượng tìm kiếm sải pháp chính trị,
cho xung đồ Đô Khuay Nè,
chứ bối cảnh các bạn tiếp tục duy trị chào đổi ở nhiều các đổ khăn nhau.
Thông tin được có bố xúc khi tần tháng ngà,
là đi mình của chiến có cuộc chào đổi kéo dài gần bốn dơ tại mắt các bạn.
Bởi các đặc phai viên của tổn thống như đương nân chăm.
Chở lý tổn thống của chiến ông Jury Ushakov đánh giả,
tất cả cuộc chào đổi về phía Mỹ mang tính thức chất xây dự và thằng tháng,
theo ông Ushakov nhóm công tất bà bên về anh liên sẽ học lần đầu tại Bú đã bị
bởi phai đơn ngà dụ cuộc chiến cuộc tình báo khu sự sẵn đầu.
Ông Ushakov cũng nhấn mạnh một điều đục ngàn nhất đi nhất lại
là bánh đe lạnh thổ cần đình dạc với theo dân thông lần chào đổi trước.
Này tổn thống Ushakov này ở vừa đia trên đánh ski cũng đã thông báo về cuộc hợp.
Con tổn thống lý đương nân chăm bài tổn lạc quan về tiến chiến sẽ với cuộc suốt.